okay I think I'm just gonna lay my cards
out on the table here I think building
front-end JavaScript applications is
insanely hard right and there are a
bunch of factors that contribute to this
and I think a part of it is that they're
just these giant balls of state and
events so I thought it would be
interesting to take a bit of a step back
and take a look at some of the take a
look at some of the patterns that we see
being applied commonly in JavaScript
applications and see if they're giving
us ways of handling state and events in
a scalable and maintainable fashion and
then what we'll do is take a look at
some of the tactics that we can use to
build on that to help us better embrace
state and events without sacrificing
clarity and our architectures but first
thanks for the introduction Ben I just
thought I'd introduce myself quickly I'm
not a llama and I come from New Zealand
it was a pretty long flight but I'm
really happy to be here in Berlin it's
my first time and it's my first time at
J's can't for you so thanks for having
me it's been a really fun time so far
and if you're over in New Zealand you
want to hang out and find out some cool
things to do you can hit me up on the
Twitter's I'm a meet on Twitter and
pretty much everywhere else on the
internet and like Ben said I work at
github now before I get started before I
really roll into this I have two
confessions to make my job at github has
like this it has nothing to do with
JavaScript don't leave just yet so I
spend my days hacking on the native
applications that github to build so I'm
on the team that does github for Mac and
github for Windows and my second
confession is I'm a Windows developer
again just hear me out before before I
was at github I was writing a lots and
lots of JavaScript and I was building
apps and backbone and in terms of
architecture JavaScript applications in
the browser actually have quite a lot in
common with their architectures that you
find on the desktop and the
thing that ties them together is the
amount of state that we concerned was
our models the state of our models the
state of all of the different views that
are being displayed on a screen at any
given point in time and then the browser
we're concerned with the state of the
address bar so it's a truckload of state
that we're all trying to keep track of
but on its own state isn't really that
interesting
what makes an application interesting
and compelling as if we're able to
interact with that state if we're able
to force new states on the application
force state transitions and state
transitions are going to occur via
events so for example we have a form and
somebody input some data into the form
and they click the Save button
and the model that backs their form is
going to transition into a new state may
be an invalid one and we've got lots of
ways that we can make interesting things
happen lots of ways that we can fire
events Dom events model events events
that are occurring on our pub/sub
channels and routing events so we've got
lots of state and we have lots of events
and it all needs to be managed and as
the complexity in our application grows
as the mount of code that we have the
amount of features that we need to
support the amount of people we have on
our team is all of that grows it becomes
harder to keep track of all of that
state and all of those events I mean how
many times have you guys seen code which
has conflated ideas like models and
views it's conflated state and views
it's conflated state with events without
a way to separate our data from our
views and our state from our event so it
all gets intertwined and we can't test
it we can't maintain it and we can't
change it and on top of all of that
we're feeling pretty shitty about it too
so without that really solid
architectural plan it's all going to
become a bit of a headache so what are
we doing rightly so we take this
inspiration from other places
design patterns which have proven to be
so particular problems like preventing
spaghetti code and this is the thing
that I really love about software
writers we actually
able to do this we can take things that
have been applied in one context and
apply that in an entirely new one and
because we can do that because we can
take inspiration from elsewhere design
patterns tend to evolve in a really
organic fashion the like ideas that
spread from one place to another and
stick because they're funny like a meme
or because they contain the solution to
a really tricky problem and if you take
the MV star family of presentation
patterns this is no exemption to that so
presentation patterns like this actually
originated out of the client
applications that were built for the
desktop so I'm talking about the small
talk days here and then over time within
web server program and became really
popular and we applied these patterns
here as well and now we're building rich
applications inside the browser and
these patterns are being applied here so
we've got frameworks like rails which
are written in an MVC style and then we
have JavaScript frameworks which are
also claiming to be implementations of
MVC what gives well I'm really not here
to turn this into a conversation of like
who's doing MVC by the book because
frankly that's pretty boring but what is
interesting is to take a look at each of
these flavors of MV whatever you want to
call them and see how they're giving us
ways of handling state and events in
each of the cases to see which ideas can
stick and which ones are causing us too
much pain and an invented and stateful
world so let's start out by taking a
look at how MVC but typically plays out
on the server and hopefully this is
going to be a reminder to you guys
actually can I see a sea of hands of
people who are comfortable talking about
MVC great it's most of you so there were
a few hands that didn't go out so I'll
be really quick and just going through
the basics we have our models they are
the guts of your application where all
the interesting things are going to
happen we have our views which are
presentations of those models and it's
typically going to be in the form of a
Jason or an HTML document and they're
basically representations of a models
current state at a given point we have
our controllers which are responsible
for C
and commands down to the model perhaps
transitioning the model states and then
returning a new snapshot a new view of
that current state now rats don't really
fit into the traditional definition of
MVC but on the server there are really
key part of the architecture our routers
are responsible for matching those
incoming web requests and delegating
that off that work off to a controller
and in action so the point that I want
to make here about how this all pertains
to how state is managed on the server
instead it's not right like we don't
have state on the server we might but we
probably don't we try and build
stateless web applications and we do
this for a number of reasons to scale
out across many servers and we achieve
this by persisting to a shared data
store of some kind which begs the
question if we try and super hard to be
stateless how are we going to make
interesting things happen to our data
how do we transition into a new state
well we address state via HTTP right so
we can say HTTP get me a list of books
at the library and if we want to delete
some of those books from the library I
don't know why you want to do that like
watching the world burn seems kind of
silly but if you did you could say HTTP
delete and what we've done here is we've
simulated a state transition across the
boundary with simulated and events so in
this world state and all state
transitions are addressable via HTTP so
our router matches a pattern the
controller has an action invoked the
models looked up and maybe has its state
transitioned and then a new snapshot has
returned so what we end up here with as
an architecture that is very linear
request comes in something may or may
not happen to the model and then a
snapshot is returned so we go down the
stack and then we go straight back up
the stick again so how does this all
relate to how the implementations player
on the client so the key difference is
on the client we are no longer trying to
be stateless we have all of the state
and memory and because we're only
servicing a single user we can do
pretty great things we can build a much
richer set of interactions and we keep a
bunch of things in memory to help us
form this cohesive application and it
comes together to form a very non linear
state-space we have our models and they
usually coupled with that snapshot that
we saw from the server and then we add
an extra layer of complexity on top of
that validation security a lot of other
kinds of behaviors so we have an
enormous amount of possible states that
our model could be in on the screen at
any given point in time we have a whole
lot of views each presenting admonish
state and together all of those views
are going to define the overall view
state of the application so what's being
presented in the sidebar can we eat it
the person contact view what's in the
main content region so all of this is
adding complexity to the state space
that we're managing and then we have the
overall state of the application right
so these are questions like which
modules are currently invoked which ones
are no longer being used can I clean
them up to free that memory all of this
is important stuff that we have to
manage and then as an added bonus we no
longer have to emulate those state
transitions across a boundary our state
in our state transitions occur within
the same execution context and that's
really empowering so when the client we
have a large state space and we move
around that state space in a really
nonlinear fashion and that
dimensionality should be reflected in
the code that we write to but in the
simplest way possible we need to be able
to test and predict how our application
is going to behave so we really need to
have a plan we need to apply some ideas
some patterns to help us achieve this so
just like on the server we bring over
those presentation patterns our models
our views and our controllers or
whatever the controller portion is that
you've brought over and then we add
routes to the equation now tradition I
mentioned earlier that traditional
implementations of MVC don't mention
routes and on the desktop this is
certainly
so this is one place where the
architectures differed quite
dramatically and so coming from the
desktop I felt a little weird about this
at first I kind of questioned like why
do we need routes how do they fit how do
I put them into my architecture without
muddying the waters and it all felt a
little weird and unnecessary until I
remembered we've got the address bar
like we totally need to be able to copy
a link send it to our friend and they
should arrive at the same state that we
see so address ability is still a really
key part of building rich single page
applications so what I want to do now is
I want to explore in question how we
commonly see routes being applied in
JavaScript apps and take a look at some
of the ways that we might structure our
code typically so I'm going to give this
example in backbone some of the object
names might be a little different in
each of the frameworks and you might not
even see some of the steps because
they're hidden behind framework code but
the series of events is pretty much
going to be the same so here we're
dealing with a party of animals because
party animals are pretty great we've got
a animal model and a list of partying
animals we have a view which defines a
template in a render function and then
we have a router now an interesting fact
about backbone routers is when backbone
first came out they were the router
object was actually originally called a
controller and I think that's led to a
lot of confusion so we have this router
and that defines two routes party and
uninvite the party one behaves a little
bit more like an HTTP GET and the
uninvite behaves a little bit more like
an HTTP delete so if we hear that
uninvite change on the address bar we're
going to invoke this function revoke
party rights and what it does is it
looks into the collection finds the
model and Christian destroys it or
transitions at state and then it moves
around into the Dom to update the state
so why is this bad so we're breaking
encapsulation here in order to push
everything right up to the top to the
routing portion of our code we have a
view that's responsible for doing some
initial rendering but and it has a
reference to our model but the first
thing that we do in the delete route
cooks off as we do an active lookup of
that model and then we transition its
state inside the router and then an even
crazier turn of events we use jQuery to
reach behind the view into the Dom to
update the view state which feels a
little weird we're really breaking
encapsulation here so we took those
flavors of MVC that we saw on a server
and we try to apply that really linear
approach to the client and then doing so
we broke encapsulation to hinge our
design around the need to support routes
so we started to treat state and events
the very thing that gives that gives us
that rich client-side experience we
started to treat them like second-class
citizens so we don't need to be
manipulating our models like the rows in
a database and models can be real and
rich and interactive we don't need to be
pushing everything up to the router and
portion of our code and subsequently
relying on routes to drive state
transitions when routes become an
architectural driver like this it
becomes hard to know who's responsible
for what you see in my mind routes are a
feature they're not an architectural
driver so the question is our routes the
enemy of the state they're totally not
the enemy right we really need routes
for addressability like I said earlier
it's an important consideration in our
overall design the thing that's causing
us pain here is and with managing state
as only using routes as the part of our
architect as a driving part of our
architecture
so we've too closely emulated the
designs that worked well for the
stateless server and as the complexity
in our front-end apps grows the cracks
in that start to show so thankfully I
think we can find a happy medium where
we can embrace the need for routes
without relying on them to drive state
transitions so the first thing I want to
do is address that bloated router code
example and drop the need to address
state transitions via a route so we
still have our models like we did before
but now our view is going to have an
event yeah it's going to have an event
hash this is nothing new backbone has
supported this for a very long time all
its going to do is when it detects a
cloak it's going to invoke a function on
the view itself it's then gonna grab the
model that it already has a reference to
transition at state and then remove
itself from the Dom so we don't have to
do any of those unnecessary lookups to
find the model we want to delete and the
view is in charge of itself right it's
in charge of the model and it's in
charge of collapsing itself from the
view okay so if we don't want to be
addressing state transitions like an
HTTP delete and we still need to support
the HTTP GET case how do we do this in a
clearer way so I just want to show you a
couple of ideas that are going to help
you do this we're going to take our
models we're gonna take our views which
render a template and then are
responsible for mediating the
interaction between the DOM and the
model and we're going to give that to a
controller object now this controller
object might keep track of a few models
and views that's totally okay not many
just a few of related functionality
we're gonna take all of that and we're
going to slide that into a module we're
gonna slide it into a single component
put a logical part of the application
and we're gonna do this for a bunch of
reasons testability composability and
frankly it's sensible now really love
this quote because it kind of describes
the idea behind modular thinking and it
basically says the whole world is trying
to build these large applications right
there's complicated apps and we should
just like get off that bus right now
because it sucks and it's going to
nowhere
we should start building smaller apps
and we should be testing those smaller
apps individually and then bringing them
all together to compose them in a larger
application after the fact and I really
like that so a module is usually defined
by a discrete area of functionality
and within that module it's free to
present any view that it wants raised
events and keep track of its own
internal state and there's several
options for implementing modules you can
hand roll your own if you just google
the module pattern and JavaScript it's a
well discussed and understood topic
you've got AMD modules comedies modules
there's lots of ways but for me the
golden rule about modules is that while
modules are free to present their views
they are never free to directly place
themselves in the Dom that
responsibility needs to go to another
object and the reason for that is
because we don't want a couple our
module our modules to the state of the
Dom at any given point in time we need
to be able to remove one module from one
page and put it somewhere else and it
should still function so the other
component that is responsible for making
this choice I'm going to call it a
layout composer and it's responsibility
is pretty obvious as to compose the UI
so it's going to define a top-level view
like a shell with regions that the
modules are able to present themselves
within and when a new module is
activated the composer is going to be
responsible for swapping the views in
and out so this is an example from a
extension to backbone called marionette
can I hit hands up with people we've
heard of marionette a few great ok so
the way that it despite the way that it
solves this problem as it has a region
manager and you can register a region
called foo and tie that to an element
bar and it's going to return a region
object or you can do the shorthand and
define them all at once so here I've got
main content region and a side bar and
then the nice thing about there as you
can say main content show and give it a
view and then internally what that's
going to do is it's going to give the
element main content to the view and it
can render itself in that place but I
think we can go a step further right so
we can take our layout composer we can
still add regions but what we should be
giving it is the module and then the
module has a reference to the element
that it is going to be rendering its
content within and then it's free to
present whatever views that it would
like in that region until the layout
composer decides that no longer
can so it's going to look a little bit
like this we've got a bunch of modules
presenting views at a micro level and a
layer composer that's responsible for
composing the mini modules that we have
running at one time so how does this
placement occur when a new module is
activated how do how does that work so
the thing that's going to be responsible
for giving modules to the layout manager
as a dispatcher and it's going to listen
to events which indicate that it's time
to load a new module and why don't one
on such events it's going to load the
target module and create an instance of
it do anything that it needs to and then
hand it over to the layout composer to
place it and the application shell and
one way that we can know that it's time
to load a new module is a routing event
right so in this design the router is
going to sit on the side and it's going
to be responsible for one thing and one
thing only it's going to listen and
observe URL changes and then when it
hears those it's going to look up which
modules need to be loaded on the screen
at any given point in time and then
raise an event to the dispatcher so I've
taken this code from a library called
Chaplin Jase has anyone heard of Chaplin
Jesus feuless hands over another library
I would really recommend you busting
open the source code for because it's
got some great patterns and one of the
things that it has as a dispatcher and
I've cut this down a little bit to get
to the key points but it just it
describes the previous route the current
modules and the current route and then
when you create the object it subscribes
to the event route match and when it
hears that basically it's going to load
the modules it's going to take the
modules that the routers decided need to
be loaded it's going to look them up
make sure that they're running make sure
that they're in memory and then hang
them off to the layout manager so we
take on the dispatcher which is
responsible for creating modules and
also managing their lifetime because an
interesting thing here is that the
layout the dispatcher knows that this
module module a is no longer in use and
we could clean that up right so it's not
responsible for managing the lifetime
and then it's also responsible for
passing those modules over to the layout
composer to whose
place them in the overall UI in one way
that the dispatcher knows that it's time
to load a new module is that a routing
event might occur and so in this way the
router remains a key feature but it's
not a driver of our architecture and
traversal around our state space can be
entirely driven by our events so we've
split up some of those concerns that
we've had around state and events and
all of the many views that we're
displaying at one time the state of the
address bar and now we have a much more
composable design we were using events
to transition into new states in a
really nonlinear fashion so if it was
all too long and you didn't read it
because reasons this conference has been
pretty great and I'm not surprised if
your brains are full I'll sum it all up
for you the management of our state
space gets really really hard when we
don't separate our concerns and on the
client we should use routes to address
States but never transitions we should
be taking ideas from one context to
another because that's awesome with
programmers that's what makes
programming fun so we can we can take
inspiration from the server about how we
include routes on the client but it's
not a rulebook we need to be able to
mold these ideas to support your
requirements like the need to be
stateful and embrace events within the
same execution context we don't need to
bake everything into the router because
it's not scalable long term and if I had
to sum up the point of all of this in
one sentence it would be don't architect
our client-side code like it's a web
server because it's not don't build
servers on the client thank you
you